I can't see any of this.
I can't see the mountaintop, or the yawning
chasm in front of me,
and this isn't some magical drone camera hovering
out in mid-air.
This is the Mixed Reality Lab at YouTube Space
New York,
and if I want to see anything around me other
than these green walls,
I'm going to have to wear this headset.
The challenge with virtual reality is that
while the person who's in it is amazed,
and waving their arms around and experiencing
it,
the rest of us don't know what's going on.
And so mixed reality is a way of letting everyone
else see
what it would be like if we were there too.
We have an actual camera that is filming you
in the headset,
in front of a green screen,
and then the game just needs to know where
the virtual camera should be.
We're using an HTC Vive for the VR, and if
we use a third hand controller
and attach that controller to the camera,
now the game understands where the camera
is
and so we can have both the actual camera
and the virtual camera
moving through the space and recording what
it would be like
if we were inside there with you.
We're using a PC that's specced-out with the
highest-end Intel processor,
32 gigs of RAM, and the current high-level
consumer video card,
which is an NVIDIA GTX 1080.
We're rendering at 4K,
and anything less than that is going to run
into an issue!
What's needed to make the mixed reality work
is a small config file that sits right in
the root folder of the game that you're playing
and that config file contains the offset between
where that controller sits
and where the actual lens of the camera is.
And then you also need to match the rotation
and the field of view of the camera
so other than that, it should work with any
recent built of Unity.
Unity is a framework for building 3D stuff
that a lot of programmers use.
And because the system ties into it,
the Mixed Reality Lab can work with a lot
of different VR games.
Not all of them, but a lot.
And because the tracking on the HTC Vive is
so accurate,
we can do things like go in for a close-up
on the laser gun
that I reckon I'm holding right now.
Granted, there's a Vive controller sticking
out of the middle of it,
but the positioning is pretty much perfect.
When you're playing in VR normally,
all the computer needs to output is the view
that you see in the headset.
When we're doing mixed reality, we also output
the view
as seen from this third controller, this virtual
camera.
And so what that gives us is four views instead
of just the one.
The four views are, yes, the headset view
as usual,
we also see the background, as seen from the
perspective of this virtual camera,
and then we have two layers of foreground,
one of them is the image itself, everything
that should appear in front of the player,
and then we have just a luma layer to help
you key out the black space.
The SteamVR plugin automatically selects the
foreground and the background
based on the position of the headset.
And anything that is between the headset and
the third controller is foreground
and anything that's beyond the headset becomes
background.
Here in our studio, we're doing a live composite
on the fly.
And this is a rough idea of what you'll get
in your final edit.
The live composite is a bit rough around the
edges,
but you can also take the original assets
and do a much more detailed composite in post-production
later.
Now, virtual studios aren't a new thing.
The BBC have been using one for election night
for years,
although it uses carefully pre-arranged graphics,
lots of expensive broadcast-quality equipment,
and the host has to rehearse and hit all their
marks exactly for things to look right.
And let's face it, replace this headset with
a Helmet of Justice
and you've got 1990s British kids show Knightmare.
All those were fancy, custom-built affairs,
though:
this uses more off-the-shelf components.
If you want to do this at home,
you're going to need a large, wrap-around
green screen,
but you could paint your walls!
You're going to need a very powerful computer,
you'll need a camera that can feed a signal
back into your computer,
you're going to need a capture card and third
controller,
but if you have all of those things,
you can build a mixed reality setup at home!
Thanks to everyone at YouTube Space New York,
and the Mixed Reality Lab.
You can find out more about them at the links
in the description.
(Are you going to keep the bump?)
(That's actually...!)
Yeah, that's nice!
All right, that's good!
That's a wrap!